spring cleaning in Havana Cubans are
working down to the wire painting houses
and repairing streets for the first time
in 88 years a US president is set to
visit many are hoping for change on the
socialists island there haven't been as
many US flags here since before the
Revolution but some Cubans are skeptical
about what the visit will achieve Berta
Solea heads up for da Mosta blanco the
ladies in white they're a group of women
who have campaigned for years for the
release of political prisoners to fight
for real change in Cuba because cosmetic
changes aren't going to solve any of our
problems
she says recent developments haven't
really made a difference we're not
afraid but we think this is not the
right time for President Obama to come
he said he would only visit when the
country makes progress on human rights
and in reality the human rights
situation has not improved independent
media abandon Cuba except online that's
because when the Cuban Constitution was
written there was no internet journalist
Alain Diaz runs a website where she can
fight for a free Akiba
and your Casa la importancia Lolita the
other players are alone in terms of
press freedom here in Cuba what we
really need is an authority or a group
to work as a kind of watchdog and make
sure that the change is happening here
are going in the right direction so come
because it's an ocean the way Angus if
you've already guessed about that body
needs to be capable of organizing a
dialogue between the government business
interests and Cuban citizens in your
face to tackle the issue young Cuban
journalists are working with supporters
from abroad
Abraham Jimenez runs an online magazine
with the help of young Cuban exiles
living in Miami Mexico and London now we
have a place to express ourselves which
belongs to us without it being
influenced by politicians or the state
that shows that things are starting to
change in Cuba when young people under
30 can start a media organization that's
a really clear sign that today's Cuba is
different Cuba's communist party is set
to hold a major Congress in April what
happens there will mark out the path
Cuba will take following Obama's visit
and offer a glimpse of how the future
could look for Cubans